ja stell einfach fest dass die Freiheit
bedroht ist in unseren westlichen
Ländern nicht jetzt irgendwo in
autoritären Staaten und zwar vom Staat
her ähm ich spreche von einer
staatlichen Ökodiktatur ich meine ich
finde es unglaublich wenn der Staat
vorschreibt welches Antriebssystem ich
beim Auto benutzen soll oder wenn es
plötzlich heißt
Verbrennungsmotoren verbieten das finde
ich einfach inakzeptabel und wir
plötzlich vorgeschrieben wie viel man
heizen darf 19 Grad oder 18 Grad 21 Grad
es geht durch den Staat nichts an und
dass das kommt immer mehr dass der Staat
Vorschriften macht und da finde ich eben
Deutschland schon auch nicht irgendwie
ein großartiges Vorbild die EU ist auch
sehr auf diesem autoritären trieb das
ist ein demokratisch nicht legitimiert
das Instrument auch die deutsche
Vorsitzende EU-Kommission ist nicht
wirklich eine gewählte Person und die
bestimmte sehr viel und es kommt sehr
von oben herab und ich glaube das
obrigkeitliche denken dass das regt
viele Bürger auf die Freiheit der Bürger
muss gestärkt werden man muss unten nach
oben legiert und nicht von oben herab
ein Schweizer lässt uns die Leviten habe
ich so das Gefühl bei ihrer These aber
wenn ich sie fragen darf mit der
Obrigkeitshörigkeit geht die denn vom
Staat aus oder von den Bürgern selbst
nehmen wir die corona-maßnahmen da kam
es mir jetzt nicht so vor als müsste der
Staat jeden einzelnen darauf hinweisen
viele Bürger waren auch gerne
quasi Impfzwang maskenvorschrift ich
meine ich habe das selbst erlebt im
Flugzeugen kulturellen Veranstaltung
kommt einfach nicht rein auf das schon
der Start der massiv einfällt ab
selbstverständlich braucht es immer zwei
bei einer materiellen Systems braucht
jemand der Befehle ausgeben es gibt es
braucht die die dann gehorchen eben
nicht geholfen habe ich ich finde schon
das ist vom Staat ein sehr autoritäres
denken gerade im Öko-Bereich ist das
unglaublich stark wieder eine Ideologie
im Hintergrund wo man sagt das ist das
Wahre und dann will man den Bürgen
vorschreiben wie sie zu leben haben und
das widersteht mir zutiefst auch als
Liberale Menschen ich glaube es geht
vielen in diesem Land leben auch so und
ja ich sage ich zeige gar nicht mit den
Fingern auf Moment ich finde auch diese
Obrigkeiten Tradition die hat vielleicht
in deutschen ein bisschen mehr
Geschichte die Schweiz ist da direkt
demokratisch ein bisschen anders
aufgestellt aber diese Tendenz gibt es
auch bei uns ich meine Corona war der
Schweizer Bundesrat hat krasse
Vorschriften gemacht und viele haben
sich da auch gedruckt und alle die sich
gewehrt haben als Spinne hingestellt
jetzt im Nachhinein muss man sagen okay
ja gut es gibt keine großen Studie
Beleges die Masken so wirksam sind es
gibt auch sehr viele Fragezeichen bei
der Impfung die aus Heilmittel verkauft
worden ist obwohl sie ja nicht wirklich
getestet worden ist also viele dieser
sogenannten Spinnen haben auf der lange
Distanz Recht bekommen und da finde ich
schon dass das die Bürger eben auch
kritisch sein müssen und das nicht
akzeptieren sollen wenn solche nicht
evidenzbasierten also nicht auf Fakten
und Erfahrung bei unseren Vorschriften
vom Staat kommen
Politiker sind wir Deutschen denn
obrigkeitshörig und das glaube ich schon
aber wir sehen das ja in vielen
Bereichen das ja auch so diese
Mainstream Politik sehen wir ja nicht
nur in der Politik sondern in vielen
anderen wissenschaftlichen Bereichen man
fragt beim vegan ganz genauso wie sie es
auch gerade gesagt haben dann schenke
ich halt nur vegan aus aber es gibt ja
in vielen Bereichen diese diese Sache
dass man einfach etwas verfolgt und den
Widerspruch können wir nicht reden weil
sofort in die Ecke kommen es gibt auch
diese Ziele die wir haben gerade im
Klimabereich die werden ja vorgegeben
man weiß eigentlich jetzt schon dass man
sie nicht erfüllen kann und anstatt man
sich an den an den an den Praktikern mal
wendet ich sage jetzt noch mal dieses
Beispiel mit den Wärmepumpen die sollen
ich glaube sechs Millionen verbaut
werden bis 2030 und wir bräuchten dafür
60.000 Handwerker die haben wir nicht
und warum reduziere ich das hier das und
Wettbewerb auch bei den Parteien da
machen wir leider Gottes auch mit von
der CDU und dann weiß ich jetzt schon in
drei Jahren ihr könnt es nicht erfüllen
und es wird von oben aber gesteuert sie
können auch nichts gegen sagen weil sie
sofort in die Ecke geschoben werden und
das ist ein riesen Problem Herr Bolz sie
haben ja schon gesagt sie sind Pensionär
sie können also eigentlich auch gut
auswandern sie sind aber noch hier
glauben sie noch an unser Land
ja selbstverständlich also ich glaube
das was man so neudeutsch resiliens
nennt so die Spannkraft die
Reaktionsfähigkeit von Deutschland vor
allem der deutschen Wirtschaft ist
gewaltig das wäre auch meine Antwort auf
die Frage von vorhin schaffen wir das
mit den mit den Flüchtlingen Deutschland
hat so unglaubliche Wirtschaftskraft
nach wie vor es ist unvorstellbar die
können ja das hat man aber jetzt schon
vier fünf mal gedacht bei Griechenland
schon bei bei der bei der aufkaufen der
DDR also immer hat mal gesagt jetzt
geht's nicht mehr weiter so aber es geht
die Sanktionen aus wir hatten es beim
Einstieg in die Sendung ich glaube das
schon also ich denke schon dass wir das
dass wir das schaffen
in diesem rein finanziellen sind
schaffen wir das alles was nicht heißt
dass wir das Problem lösen oder dass wir
mit dem Problem sinnvoll umgehen aber
ich denke in der Tat es ist so dass die
Deutschen mehr als andere Länder in
Europa
obrigkeitshörig sind also der der
Untertan von Heinrich Mann das ist immer
noch ein sehr aktuelles Buch und die
Deutschen werden werden ständig so wie
anderen Europäer auch aber sie reagieren
anders mit großem Straße demonstrieren
jetzt auch gegen Energiepreise absolut
drin nicht alles nur Untertan wir haben
vollkommen recht das die müssen ja dann
auch mit diesem Schicksal leben dass sie
als Rechtsaußen oder als Spinner oder
als ewig Gestrige behandelt werden aber
ich denke die Mehrheit der Deutschen
wird doch von den großen weltpolitischen
Themen immer angesprochen in den
Registern Angst und Sicherheit also man
macht ihnen Angst oder das was passiert
macht ihnen Angst und unsere Politik ist
eine die ihnen absolutes Sicherheit
immer wieder verspricht so dass wir
meistens bereit sind Freiheit für
Sicherheit zu opfern und das ist etwas
was man an vielen vielen Themen auch an
Ukraine Krieg und an alle
einhaken bei der Ukraine und ich dachte
mir wir können ja direkt mal Streit hier
am Tisch Proben ja wir sagen wir wollen
streiten ich vermute dass sie und Herr
gut eine ganz andere Meinung zu den
Wirtschaft zu tun haben das vermute ich
jetzt einfach mal deswegen würde ich da
sich auch mal direkt bitten ob sie die
denn eigentlich für sinnvoll halten für
unser Land aber das die Antwort gebe ich
wirklich als krasser Laie ich weiß so
wenig von dem Ukraine Konflikt und ich
kenne die Ukraine nicht Russland auch
nicht ich habe nur wie jeder normale
Bürger eine Meinung und ein Gefühl und
mein Gefühl sagt mir es ist richtig die
Ukraine zu unterstützen es ist richtig
diese Wirtschaftssanktionen zu erheben
solange Sie uns nicht vollkommen
strangulieren jedenfalls also solange es
nicht in notwehrmaßnahmen aus sich
wirken muss trotzdem würde ich sagen und
das ist das für mein Thema ja auch
entscheidend wichtige Leute die das für
falsch halten die überhaupt unsere ganze
Ukraine Politik für falsch halten das
sind keine Spinner die sind nicht
verrückt sondern die haben einfach eine
andere Einschätzung einer extrem
komplexen Lage und ich glaube wir machen
uns bei vielen Themen nicht wirklich
deutlich wie komplex die Situation sind
und wie laienhaft unser normales Urteil
eigentlich ist und dass wir eigentlich
ein vitales Interesse daran haben
müssten das kompetente Leute im Streit
uns verschiedene Aspekte eines Themas
entwickeln
nein ich Subvention sehe ich schon ein
bisschen anders ich meine das wurde aus
als grosses Instrument ganz stark tönend
oder von der EU er da präpariert und
wenn ich einfach sehe wie es
funktioniert muss ich sagen es hat nicht
das gebracht was man sich davon
versprochen hat immer diese nüchterne
Kosten Nutzenanalyse muss ja wohl noch
möglich sein und ich sehe einfach zum
Beispiel schauen Sie Gazprom an erstes
Halbjahr 2022 eine Rekord Erlebnis die
aber noch nie so viel verdient mit
Export von Gas und Öl da muss auch sagen
irgendwo sind diese Subventionen nicht
das was man sich da versprochen hat
innerhalb der Welt kann man das
Exportieren anderen Ländern ist das Furz
egal was da passiert das ist in der EU
sozusagen
die Politik man denkt er muss irgendwas
entgegensetzen aber muss nachschauen was
nützt das und wenn es am Ende so ist
dass es es gibt Leute in Russland ich
habe es letztes Mal eine Sendung in
Österreich erzählt habe ich auch
geferscht natürlich wiederhole es gerne
was du diese Meinung geben stehe die
Leute dort die Leben von einer Pension
von rund 200 Euro im Monat und dann
müsste alles bezahlen Medikamente es
gibt keine Krankenkassen nichts und wenn
jetzt eine ältere Dame die davon lebt
ist jetzt betroffen zum Beispiel
Geldtransfers das ist nötig das
Verwandte Bekannte hier in Westeuropa
Geld schickt das ist nicht mehr erlaubt
das einfache Bild ich muss kein alligat
sein ich kann nicht einen beliebigen
Russen Geld überweisen Moment das ist
doch einfach krank da muss man sagen
pack den Putin das ist ein Aggressor der
hat ein Verbrechen begangen nämlich
Angriffskrieg das ist völkerrechtlich
gerecht da bin ich völlig bei Ihnen oder
vermutlich bei allen hier am Tisch aber
es geht nicht dass man dann einfach
solche mit der Streumunition quasi mit
der Schrotflinte da Subventionen es
Sanktion macht die einfach auch die
forschende das ist momentan der Fall und
das muss man auch sehen konnte noch
hinzu was passiert kann ich hier wenn Du
uns am Schluss so stark ins eigene
Fleisch schneiden dass wir im Winter
frieren dass wir unsere Wirtschaft
zugrunde geht weil wir keine gime haben
dann lacht jeder Putin doppelt ins Feuer
da muss man schon sagen das ist nicht
der der Weisheit letzter Schluss was sie
da beschossen haben aber ich meine es
wäre ja absolut heuchlerisch wenn man
zum einen Angst davor hätte schwere
Waffen zu liefern um nicht den Krieg
total eskalieren zu lassen wenn man zum
anderen sich ausdrücklich für die Sache
der Ukraine aussprechen würde also
Solidarität mit der Ukraine programmiert
und dann aber mit Russland Handel treibt
wie eh und je ohne irgendein Alter das
wäre reine Heuchelei ich gebe Ihnen ja
zu dass diese Wirtschaftssanktionen viel
weniger wirken oder vielleicht völlig
unwirksam sind ich glaube aber nicht
dass das so vollkommen überraschend
kommt für die Politiker sondern diese
Wirtschaftssanktionen haben auch glaube
ich eine große symbolische Bedeutung
lernplatz aber wie sehen Sie das Herr
dohrendorf ich meine hier die die es
wurde ja gesagt die Politik hat das
einkalkuliert glauben sie das auch dass
die Wirksamkeit ein bzw die fehlende
Wirksamkeit naja ist halt ein bisschen
schwierig also man musste auf jeden Fall
reagieren das hat man ja einen anderen
Stellen leider nicht gemacht in vielen
Bereichen und Putin der testet einfach
nur aus das sind Adresse der sieht seine
Macht und wer da wer da nicht gegen geht
da hat er keine hat er keine Chance
zieht er seine Sachen durch also das hat
man sicherlich ein bisschen mit
einkalkuliert aber man musste natürlich
auch etwas machen das was sie sagen es
kann nicht sein dass man sich beschwert
aber dann Handel betreibt sondern da
muss natürlich etwas kommen ob es
wirksam ist wie sie es gesagt haben es
ist mit Fragezeichen zu behaften aber
man muss auf jeden Fall reagieren die
Menschen in ihrem Wahlkreis weil wenn
man jetzt zum Beispiel auch aktuelle
Umfragen anschaut die Deutschen sind
jetzt nicht alle für die Sanktion nein
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir
haben natürlich sehr viele junge jetzt
in Deutschland fast eine Million Ukraine
bei uns sind auch sehr viele bei uns in
Nürnberg muss ich sagen wir haben sehr
engen Kontakt mit denen und wenn sie
natürlich die Schilderungen bekommen wie
sie behandelt worden ist was die erlebt
haben haben sie einen ganz anderes
Verständnis als wenn sie noch mal ab und
zu in der Zeitung lesen was weit weg ist
da sind wir schon sehr bei den Ukrainern
und versuchen dort zu helfen und können
das auch ein Stück weit verstehen ganz
klar
ist wie blicken Sie darauf ich meine sie
sind wahrscheinlich der hier der am
meisten Einblick auch in die
Außenpolitik in anderen Ländern hat man
kann ja schon sagen dass Russland und
China immer enger auch jetzt dadurch
zusammenrücken können wir Deutsch
überhaupt was ausrichten auf jeden Fall
und das ist genau der Punkt also was
mich stört ist dass es hier viel zu sehr
aus der deutschen und europäischen
Brille gesehen wird und so getan wird
als ob die ganze Welt jetzt Russland
verurteilen würde und das ist ja leider
muss man sagen nicht so sondern wir
haben eine Situation wie wir es hier
noch nie hatten auf der Welt dass China
ein wirtschaftlich absolut mächtiges
Land geworden ist ganz anders als in der
Zeit des Kalten Krieges wo die
Sowjetunion wie Helmut Schmidt damals
sagte oberwolter mit Atomraketen
militärisch stark aber wirtschaftlich
überhaupt nicht jetzt haben wir mit
China ein wirtschaftlich ganz starkes
Land und anders als in der Zeit wobei
das sehr viel schwächer waren sind ja
China und russ heute zusammen damals
waren ja
Sowjetunion und China hat sich ja
verkracht und das hatte dann Nixen
genutzt um China mehr oder weniger auf
die Seite des Westen zu ziehen jetzt
sind die beiden zusammen China freut
sich natürlich über das Öl dass sie
jetzt aus Russland beziehen also ich bin
völlig bei ihnen Putin aggressa wir
müssen überlegen was wir machen und was
auch was bringt aber wir sollten uns
nicht der Illusion hingeben dass wir da
so stark sein sondern es formt sich da
ein Block der wirtschaftlich stark ist
und der von der Bevölkerungszahl her
auch viel viel größer ist als wir alle
zusammen